the crackdown on america's civil  liberties is coming we told you that  yesterday  it turns out it didn't take long it is  here now and it's  unprecedented and it will have  consequences  this will cause extremism actions taken  to suppress  extremism will cause it  those unintended consequences we don't  know is very clear  what's happening and what will happen  here's the first news  just days after donald trump called for  breaking up the big tech monopolies in  order to preserve democracy the big tech  monopolies  have silenced him twitter has just  announced the sitting president has been  banned permanently from the platform  that is his primary means  of public communication of course they  waited till the democratic party took  power  and they shut it down they are in  control now  silicon valley oligarchs are more  powerful than the president of the  united states and they want you to know  it  everywhere the assault on speech  accelerates